Bonjour!
Bienvenue!
Thank you all for coming.
This show is full of pieces
we've been told
to keep hidden.
We're impressed upon
to enhance our bodies,
but we're not supposed
to talk about it.
Well, this collection
was designed to be seen.
This collection
was designed to be loud.
I would love to welcome
a very dear friend
and mentor,
who taught me everything
I needed to unlearn
to create
this collection today.
I believe that
he's here with us now.
Pierre Cadeau.
Pierre? Where are you?
What the hell's going on?
This isn't in the timeline.
You magnificent bitch.
Long live the king!
Well,
now that that's over,
mesdames et messieurs,
let them eat cake.